so this guy edy Klein has written a book
called blood feud and it's all about how
the Obamas hate the Clintons and the
Clintons hate the Obamas it's like Romeo
and Juliet and he summed up his book in
a New York Post piece yesterday let's
take a look at what he said so Obama has
authorized his chief political advisor
Valerie Jarrett to convince Elizabeth
Warren to run she is the progressive
obviously in Massachusetts we'll talk
about it more in a second
Jarrett has held a series of secret
meetings with Warren where she explained
that Obama is worried that if Hillary
succeeds him in the White House she may
undo many of his policies basically
implying that Hillary isn't as left as
Obama is and she's more of a centrist
and Obama's not happy about that and
Obama believes that Warren is the best
person that convinced the party that
Hillary is out of touch with poor
Americans and the middle class Warren in
his view would carry on the Obama legacy
after he leaves the White House then it
gets into a lot of personal stuff about
why they hate each other and that
Clinton has talked about how much he
hates Obama and all that stuff we talked
in the last couple weeks a lot about how
Hillary keeps pretending she's poor she
says she went into the White House broke
and she came out in debt no just really
just not true she's never not had a meal
that she wanted to have at any fancy
restaurant but I think this is kind of
interesting that Obama he was her
Secretary of State everyone thinks that
you know he brought her in doing this
Lincoln sorry she was his Secretary's
day whoever one of the one one way or
the other but that everyone thinks that
they sort of made buddy-buddy and he did
like the Abraham Lincoln thing in you
know where you bring in people that you
don't necessarily agree with to kind of
just coalesce around you Doris Kearns
Goodwin in school yeah that book in the
period the whole thing so I think this
is kind of interesting that if any of
this is true and I don't know that it is
but this guy seems to have done his
research that he really wants someone
else besides her to run someone that was
in his administration what do you make I
mean I think that this article is a lot
of fear-mongering so is the book trying
to be divisive in this moment and try to
make Hillary seem out of touch and
everything else like that I mean the
Republicans should be afraid of
Hillary running and clearly they are you
know III
like Elizabeth Warren a lot yeah and so
for me the thought of her running for
president is very exciting we've had a
Clinton and a bush in the White House
for a very very long time so to get a
little bit of fresh perspective is
exciting to me but I think that this
book is sort of a lot of fear that we're
putting on yeah I agree and I don't want
to focus on the book it just sort of
because yeah this guy we don't know if a
lot of this is true but the general idea
of that Elizabeth Warren would be much
better if we really want change in this
country and we want and the banks I mean
Hillary's taken a ton from goldman sachs
you just took four hundred thousand for
two speeches but shouldn't we all want
to Michael is you know the politics you
don't if you don't always get the person
you want or the best person in office
because you you really have to be
concerned with who's electable right and
so you think she'd be like off the deep
end for most sort of middle well I think
she would be harder to put in office I
think and I'm certainly no political
sage I think that she would be harder to
put into office than Clinton at this
point Clinton has so much momentum yeah
and just there would be a lot that I
think Warren would have to do yes to get
up to that point but I like her yeah I
really do like her a lot do you think
Hillary risks her momentum is a little
too early I mean this election is still
almost two years away you know yeah but
it's a it's important it's an important
time right now I mean III think that
you're absolutely right like Warren
would have a very hard time getting
elected and Clinton's the shoe and now
for me Obama has to also see all that
we're talking about his legacy here so
it also is this stuff really true with
this guys like you know opposed to me I
mean I see the name New York Post and I
just don't you know I and that's that
maybe not fair that's not fair of me you
like how in the first two stories we've
done I linked you to Breitbart comma New
York Post no I mean like keep horses
yeah I'm trying to get sources that
maybe we don't agree with a little bit
ya know but I think it's an interest I
think it's interesting to think about
Warren in this case and also think about
Hillary and
and and and in this moment it's
important that that we I think that my
party at least rallies around somebody
who we think can really bring about the
the most change for this kind of I don't
even say change again but no we're at a
critical word like this critical
junction with the environment and with
immigration now and certainly with the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court is
gonna hang in the balance with whoever
is electronic so this is like a critical
moment yeah but also you know you know
III think all of us are naive when it
comes to politics because who knows what
what what Warren really is and who's
behind her and what they're
manufacturing for her and stuff I mean
it's politics there's gotta be something
well I think that about everything but
it's used sort of gotta just pick some
stuff to believe and then run with it
otherwise you know who the hell knows
what's in char who's in charge or what I
mean do you think women would turn
against Elizabeth Warren if she ran
against Hillary because obviously women
hugely are supporting Hillary and I
don't think it's just because she's a
woman but the idea that another woman
would then try to run against her which
then they'd say you're gonna split the
female with the female vote and then not
because that's so stupid right mean it's
like but you know they'd say it you know
they say it right well you know they
love to do that they let they love to
paint women as cat fighters you know and
and that and that's insulting right it's
just men didn't turn against Ross Perot
opera no but it's always you know women
are always seen as a novelty still right
yeah we're a novelty it's like that is a
comic yeah you know when you when you're
on a show will again have to women
understand that of a man she said every
time but you know I'm just I'm it's it's
it's an unfair it's an unfair highlight
yeah I just
I ate it bothers me and I
and I'm not saying it's not gonna be
done but it's wrong yeah all right so
final thought on this should we care
what an outgoing president thinks or who
he endorses like even if you love Obama
whoever the president is but at that
point you had your run you had your
eight years you did everything you could
do for good or bad and then at that
point we just shouldn't matter who you
endorse that's sort of what I think like
that's the George W Bush school event
right disappear into the clear brush
yeah yeah I don't know for me I think
it's it's vital it's important what you
know what President Clinton comes and
stands behind it it's important I think
who w endorses and it's important for me
who karl rove endorses is important for
me who all of these guys rumsfeld that
that is gonna paint a lot i think of
these people right it's like anything in
life i mean you want to go to a doctor
you get a referral i mean you know you
want you want to know what other people
think
right whom you admire or whom you
respect um you don't respect yeah
although whether or not the political
climate shows that an endorsement from
obama is actually gonna be a negative
and the all i mean that's the other
thing
right after well it's gonna be negative
somebody right you know indeed it will